yeah as long as you make 150 and the
bond is going to be right
yeah I think you can you can create a
lot I think I think families are awesome
and having kids and all of that so so if
I make 150 okay
back to the regular dude
I make a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars a year
right
take him back he makes 70 dollars he's a
really good guy okay he looked at your
content and said you know what I can get
past it I can rock with that but I want
you
and that's no good though right
70 is no good
um no I've dated men who've made 70k but
she's but the minimum is 150 though well
right now I think because I've made more
money it definitely went higher so so if
I'm making so if I do make a 70. if I
have an undeniable connection with
someone they're my ride or die they
support me they build me up then at the
end of the day we're gonna figure it out
financially and I have no problem
supporting my man and and taking on a
role that helps us build together like
what I care about at the end of the day
is having somebody that like I know is
for me and I'm for them and I think that
is way more important than what a man 70
for the rest of your life
and then adjust it for inflation is no
good though right what I want somebody
who's okay with just staying at that
level no I would not but
wait I'm sorry could you what percent of
guys do you think make that amount of
money
150 150 oh that's like top one percent
right yeah I thought type one percent
was 500 no
no
damn one percent's only 150. that might
be a percentage of a percent I think I
think like less about how much money you
make and like what are your goals and
aspirations are you growing are you
working on yourself if you stay stagnant
and you're just making that money like
I'm just gonna look at you as at 70 000
person
at 70 you know the average household
income isn't even 70 000 in the United
States of America
yeah and that's the household and isn't
it like a hundred dollars
families have more divorces because
based off of like a couple hundred
dollars if they had more Financial
Security and a couple of hundred dollars
more they actually wouldn't be having as
many issues as they are I don't think so
I think Financial stress plays a huge
role in marriages and divorces what do
you think
and it could be over a couple but a
couple hundred dollars is not going to
be the determining factor for whether or
not but if it's a couple hundred dollars
every couple years or every month think
about what y'all just said I just don't
know where we got this no I mean they're
actually right a couple hundred dollars
a year that stress adds up I mean what I
don't you know I'm not the stats person
right but what is it like 60 percent of
families in the United States can't get
like four hundred dollars in cash in 30
days
in 30 days so I mean a flat tire can can
represent debilitate you catastrophe for
so many families
and so and I think it's even more maybe
it's like 40 can't get uh
uh four hundred dollars and then like
sixty percent of families can't get like
a thousand or something like that but
something super low and in 30 days so
when she's saying you know 200 300 can
we can make a break a family or at least
put extreme pressure on a relationship
in a marriage absolutely right I mean
these families are struggling in America
yeah but 70k
70 is like the new like 30.
household income is under average across
the entire United States of America
under 70.
I don't think about it like this that's
the average household that's everybody
in the house right working together and
I asked you if you would be satisfied
with just one person him specifically
making 70. that don't mean that you
can't go get a job too oh if I can get a
job then absolutely
because I feel like a lot of just like I
guess in the situation that you're in
like your wife works underneath you and
with you like I think a lot of people
want that they would rather their like
wife working for them than like out at
another job but I mean she still works
though is my point yeah but you're
amazing I've created a space where she's
able to add value into what it is that
I've already built
but that don't absolve her from working
even so I've dated somebody I did while
I was in sales and I was making uh six
figures
um my significant other at the time was
making like 80k and I had another I
guess two boyfriends one was making 50K
um and he came from a rich family like
Daddy's Money drove like Jaguars and had
Ferraris and all this stuff and so he
was so used to being like the rich one
and then he dated me and he was all
about me like being a a boss [__] and
all that stuff and he supported me and I
think because he was in sales he had a
long sales cycle so his him's closing a
deal is once every six months I was in
marketing I'm closing deals the moment I
pick up the phone so I get home I'm like
I just closed three Deals and hit my
quota and it's like very exciting and
I'm making money and I think it put he
didn't like that I made more money than
him it like was an insecurity thing so
it really depends on like the situation
what's my job how much money am I making
if he's making 70 and I'm making a
hundred
that the ego battle not on my end but
just like making him feel insecure
because I'm more of the provider there'd
be an issue I'm just
six figures so I'm just like wondering
where like where this comes from because
I hear it's really common like like I
hear girls say it all the time but it's
like that's the top one percent guy like
what what makes I would even say me like
I wouldn't think like what makes me so
special that I deserve a one percent guy
so I guess well you grew up very
privileged so you your parents make good
money like you would think I'd be the
one saying it you would think
but if you've never experienced what
it's like to not eat like not have heat
or like cold like or warm water to like
struggle because and you watch your
family like destroy themselves over
trying to provide for you as like a kid
like you spend your whole life wanting
to do everything to avoid that and I
think a lot of women go right into like
okay men will be the provider and
they're going immediately up to that
do I necessarily think that's like every
person should have that expectation
absolutely not but I think Financial
insecurity drives a lot of decisions of
what people make yeah I don't know I had
a really really good good friend she's
homeless for a while she would never say
six figures I don't know why it just
comes like I just don't know where it
comes from
I guess it's because I know I can make
it and I know like I'm a hustler and I
want someone that has those those
qualities so that I can step more into
like my femininity and not be a freaking
Hustler I just but I feel like I can
still be feminine even if I make money
yeah for sure it's something like women
really have a a view that they can get
the best man and I think that's a
bolster by the fact that women can look
around and see let's say unattractive or
fat or otherwise undesirable women with
men that make six figures right so if I
can look around and see five women who
look worse than me with men with six
figures like well of course I can get
one if you give me enough time right if
I can get a man making 150 000 why would
I settle for a man making 70. and it's
proof that I can get this man with 150
000 because I'm seeing all these other
women with men who make 150 000 and
these women look worse than me
but the other side of that though is
that a lot of those women were with
those guys way before he started making
150 000 dollars
I absolutely do believe in like sticking
with your man as he grows so like if a
man's like hey I'm making 50k now but
here are my goals and this is what I
want to do then like yeah let's eat [__]
together well like because you're
working on that you just said that your
traumas wants you to they make you one
but at that point I'm more I'm
financially secure but you're not though
because the guy's making 50 Grand so but
what if I'm making 100K and I can
provide a sense a little bit of a
contradiction there because at first you
said that your traumas made it to where
you wanted to be as far apart uh from
the situation where you know you have to
eat [__] and you don't have housing and
Light and Water and now you're saying
well you know if my guy is poor you know
I'm fine with that as long as at some
point we're working into the future I
can understand how that's contradicting
absolutely but I think when we talk
about our trauma like
just because I have those feelings and
just because there's that Financial
insecurity I think before I never worked
through that and that led to how I moved
in terms of dating well that's an
important thing I think working through
that trauma allows me to be a little bit
safe and not be like so oh my God we
need money and it's gonna be like the
end of the world if they're not making
good money does that make sense
no but also in this scenario we've
extended it to where he's not the only
provider where you guys said we could
also be working so if a man's making 70k
and I can't work and make up that
difference then maybe I couldn't date
somebody only making 70k if I can work
and I'm making enough money where I feel
stable and I don't have to worry about
that two three hundred dollar windfall
then he can make less until he works
towards making more as I would be doing
if we're both career people would you go
down and lifestyle for a family you yeah
yeah absolutely no traveling yeah at all
yeah I don't believe that no um what
about no new clothes like you can get
clothes once a year it's like 300 bucks
that's honestly pretty much what I spend
now oh yeah so like I don't I don't have
anything designer I don't I don't like
to like I don't invest in like nice
stuff pretty much because I don't like
take care of it but so like I don't
spend a lot on clothes like what I'm
spending money on is like the podcast
the guy I dated a man who had a
two-year-old son and he was separated
from or you're not together with the
baby mama and I was in sales and I was
making more money than him and he
everything kind of clicked for me like I
need a man who has like a good family
because I don't so I think that's very
important so he had the good family they
liked me I had a good relationship with
his son and it was in New Hampshire do I
want to live in New Hampshire and did I
want to do that no but I loved him and I
loved his son and I loved his family and
I was willing to
put that first
um and I think when that hair dye what
no hair dye I didn't yeah I didn't even
have red hair then I did this to the
lifestyle we're going down and no hair
dye yeah go back to Brown what about
this is more for marketing because
you'll always remember the two redheads
even if you don't know her name
actually yeah
if I had a family then my family would
100 be my first priority and if I was
married to somebody and they loved me
they would not give a [__] about I was
not wearing makeup yeah but I'm saying
so like then what about the so then why
do we need the 120 150. I just don't
want to go and we can go down and
lifestyle like Auntie Jenny was telling
me she thinks she could really just a
kid with like two to five hundred a
month that's
actually no I've been talking to wives
that actually do this and it's literally
like they never eat out they never they
cook every single meal yeah only buy the
food that's not clear like and I haven't
lived this so I'm maybe maybe they're
capping I don't know but I've talked to
like multiple wives that are telling me
no you can you can live on this amount
of money but like people don't want to
go down a lifestyle they don't want to
live outside of the city and commute
basically for their husbands yeah um
it's gonna be open to it for the right
person okay so you would so then maybe
maybe 45 000 a year yeah you'd give a
chance as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible